[Música]
al menos 16 personas murieron y otras 59
resultaron heridas por dos misiles rusos
que estallaron contra un centro
comercial el hecho ocurrió en la ciudad
de kremeniuk en el centro de ucrania la
onu y occidente rechazando el ataque
el g7 reiteró que respaldará a ucrania
el tiempo que sea necesario para
combatir a las tropas rusas el
presidente de vuelo vivir selenski habló
con los líderes de los siete países en
el segundo día de la cumbre la jornada
se centró en la guerra
en francia terminó el megajuicio por los
atentados de noviembre de 2015 en parís
los acusados se dirigieron por última
vez al tribunal entre ellos a la aps
alemán el único sobreviviente de los
atacantes la sentencia se conocerá el
próximo miércoles
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
estar con ustedes
empezamos en ucrania este lunes varios
puntos civiles fueron atacados en
lysychansk al este murieron al menos
ocho personas y otras 21 resultaron
heridas el gobierno local afirma que
ellas estaban recolectando agua en un
carro cisterna cuando los misiles rusos
impactaron más hacia el oeste en la
ciudad de crimen chuck un centro
comercial fue atacado con dos rockets 16
personas murieron y 59 están heridas
desde la ciudad de jarquín nuestra
enviada especial leticia álvarez tiene
los detalles de este ataque
y condena unánime internacional el
ataque con misiles contra un centro
comercial en la región de poltava muy
alejado de objetivos militares el
portavoz de la secretaria general de
naciones unidas lo ha calificado de
deplorable y el propio primer ministro
británico boris johnson ha denunciado el
barbarismo de vladimir putin este ataque
contra civiles se produce en plena
reunión del g7 donde los líderes de las
principales naciones industrializadas en
la unión europea han mostrado su
solidaridad con ucrania y su intención
de seguir apoyando a este país el tiempo
que haga falta por taba es una región
alejada del frente que sirve de centro
para acoger a refugiados que huyen de
zonas mucho más complicadas como la que
nos encontramos en jarquín y también es
un centro para las sedes de las
organizaciones internacionales mañana es
un día feriado aquí en ucrania es el día
de la constitución y las autoridades han
pedido a los ciudadanos que se alejen de
las aglomeraciones de los centros
comerciales y que eviten ponerse en
peligro y hacer caso a las alarmas
porque la situación está empeorando las
fronteras están desdibujando y rusa está
ganando terreno no son el donbass
también aquí en jarkiv el número de
ataques lo hemos podido comprobar estas
últimas noches sigue aumentando en el
este de ucrania
y precisamente ucrania fue el tema
central de la segunda jornada de la
cumbre del g7 que se realiza hasta
mañana en alemania los líderes de los
siete países conversaron por
videollamada con volodymyr selenski el
mandatario ucraniano y prometieron que
seguirán respaldando aquí es tanto
tiempo como sea necesario
luís muñoz nos amplía la historia
promesas para ucrania el grupo de los
países más ricos del mundo el g7 en su
segunda jornada de cumbre en alemania
conversó por videoconferencia con
volodymyr selenski presidente ucraniano
en un comunicado los principales líderes
mundiales prometieron seguir ayudando a
combatir la invasión rusa
seguiremos brindando apoyo financiero
humanitario militar y diplomático y
apoyaremos a ucrania todo el tiempo que
sea necesario es la respuesta a las
peticiones que les hizo de lenski este
reveló en telegram el contenido de la
conversación
ucrania siente el apoyo de los estados
del g7
gracias por su defensa y asistencia
financiera a nuestro país en la lucha
contra la invasión rusa para nosotros la
posición coherente de los países del g7
sobre las sanciones también es
importante deben seguir aumentando en
particular limitando el precio del
petróleo exportado del agresor
en otro mensaje excelente y concreto en
cinco puntos las peticiones seguridad
reanudación de exportaciones agrícolas
reconocer a rusia como patrocinador del
terrorismo
reconstrucción del país y más defensa
antimisiles a este último punto se
comprometió el asesor de seguridad
nacional de la casa blanca jake sullivan
por su parte el canciller alemán olaf
scholz anfitrión de la cumbre se mostró
satisfecho todas nuestras políticas
están alineadas este creo es un buen
mensaje estamos tomando decisiones
difíciles y esto es lo esencial para ser
duros y pensar en las necesidades del
tiempo que estamos viviendo
el g7 está formado por alemania eeuu
francia italia canadá japón y reino
unido- en éste 2022 ya han comprometido
29 mil 500 millones de dólares en apoyo
a ucrania de alemania pasamos al sur de
asia el gobierno de sri lanka limitará a
partir de hoy el uso del combustible
hasta el 10 de julio sólo lo permitirá
para servicios esenciales como la salud
los trenes los autobuses o los vehículos
que transporten alimentos estas medidas
intentan apaciguar la peor crisis
económica que ha habido en el país en
siete décadas
una grave escasez de combustible es la
expresión de la peor crisis económica de
sri lanka en siete décadas en un intento
desesperado para hacer frente a esta
situación las autoridades cerraron las
escuelas en colombo la capital pidieron
a los empleados públicos que trabajen
desde casa e informaron que sólo
suministran combustible a los servicios
esenciales como la sanidad los trenes y
los autobuses durante dos semanas a
partir del martes los ciudadanos hacen
largas colas para comprar gasolina
llevo aquí desde la medianoche del
viernes cuando llegamos habían dejado de
bombear gasolina no sé si tendré
gasolina o no de momento me han dado un
vale
entretanto una delegación de alto nivel
de los departamentos de tesoro y de
estado de eeuu se reunió con los
dirigentes de la isla para explorar las
formas de brindar ayuda mientras que un
equipo del fondo monetario internacional
llegó para mantener conversaciones sobre
un posible paquete de rescate de tres
mil millones de dólares el país asiático
ya había recibido cuatro mil millones de
ayuda financiera de su vecina india y
las autoridades han hecho un llamado a
la austeridad
tendremos que enfrentarnos a varios
retos a veces podremos acabar con las
colas de gasolina por completo otras
veces no podremos acabar con las colas
creo que no podremos obtener 550 560
millones de dólares en los próximos
meses definitivamente tendremos que
reducir nuestro consumo a 350 millones
de dólares
de youtube la oposición y una gran
mayoría de ciudadanos exigen la dimisión
del presidente gotabaya rajapaksa su
hermano el ex primer ministro imagina
rajapaksa renunció en mayo por la misma
razón la familia es acusada de acaparar
y dar mal manejo a los negocios del
estado precipitando la crisis actual
mientras que la demanda de pasaportes se
ha disparado ya que muchos intentan huir
del país
y el aumento de los precios del petróleo
también golpea a ecuador allí se cumplen
15 días de protestas en la que los
indígenas rechazan el alza de los costos
de vida hoy accedieron a dialogar con el
gobierno pero el presidente guillermo
lasso no asistió el mandatario se dio en
una de las demandas y rebajó los precios
de la gasolina y del diesel en 10
centavos por galón cuando la exigencia
era que bajara más de 40 centavos
un nuevo intento por frenar las
protestas favoreciendo la baja del
combustible el presidente guillermo
lasso espera abordar una de las
principales demandas de los indígenas he
decidido reducir el precio de la
gasolina extra y echo país en 10
centavos por galón y el diésel también
en 10 centavos por galón
la medida se da luego que él lanzó
levantar el estado de emergencia que
había impuesto en seis provincias y de
iniciar un diálogo con los líderes de
las protestas en ese país la producción
petrolera se encuentra en niveles
críticos y ha disminuido el 50 por
ciento de su producción dejando de
percibir alrededor de 120 millones de
dólares según el ministerio de energía
los precios de los combustibles ya
estaban congelados desde el año pasado
todos consideran que el precio de los
combustibles se ha convertido en la
piedra angular que mantiene el conflicto
y aunque como gobierno tenemos muy claro
que este factor no es el que origina los
problemas de los ecuatorianos debemos
pensar en el bien común y la paz
ciudadana los indígenas también piden el
control de los precios de los productos
agrícolas y un mayor presupuesto para la
educación para ellos el reciente anuncio
no es suficiente
para conseguir nuestros derechos fiestas
menos
a quién tenemos
el cierre de las vías y la escasez han
provocado también algunas
manifestaciones contra los bloqueos que
iniciaron el pasado 13 de junio
entretanto los legisladores discuten una
solicitud de la oposición para destituir
al presidente lazo aunque se requiere el
voto de al menos 92 de los 137
legisladores una cifra difícil de
alcanzar tomando en cuenta que la
oposición cuenta con apenas 50 curules
en un camión en texas eeuu encontraron
cerca de 40 cadáveres
el vehículo fue hallado junto a las vías
del tren a las afueras de la ciudad de
san antonio el ministerio de relaciones
exteriores de méxico confirmó que los
muertos eran migrantes aunque sus
nacionalidades se desconocen y no se
sabe con precisión qué pasó marcelo
ebrad el canciller mexicano viajará al
lugar de los hechos
hoy terminaron las audiencias por los
atentados en francia ocurridos el 13 de
noviembre de 2015 y en los que murieron
130 personas el próximo 29 de junio se
conocerá el veredicto y los fiscales
pidieron penas de 5 a 30 años de cárcel
para los acusados además pidieron cadena
perpetua sin libertad condicional para
sala absalam el único sobreviviente de
los comandos que efectuaron los ataques
erika olavarría nos cuenta la historia
de las familias de una de las víctimas
dos días después de iniciado el proceso
el pasado 8 de septiembre financia esta
chilena que perdió a su hijo luís felipe
en la sala de conciertos bataclán
aterrizaba en parís
no tenía abogado tampoco se había
constituido en parte el civil y ni
siquiera tenía unas vacunas reconocidas
por francia pero sabía que quería estar
presente
en estos meses nancy consiguió un
abogado que habla español pero también
se armó toda una vida en parís con lado
nicolás este hotel que paga el estado
francés se ha convertido en su casa
esta gente me ha cogido súper bien bueno
tanto tiempo que permaneció acá pero han
sido para mí súper súper súper
acogedores y les pille el eje estoy en
el proceso por lo tanto
necesito permanecer en un lugar mucho
tiempo y bueno me preguntaron por qué
que siguió entonces yo empecé a explicar
y ellos tienen estos estos estos
atentados muy en la retina
todos fueron muy afectados por esto
en el escritorio de la pequeña
habitación revistas y libros que hablan
de este proceso fuera de lo común son un
regalo de un policía su intérprete o la
madre de otra de las víctimas he tenido
mucha mucha información
respecto a cómo pasó en el bataclán como
entraron al bataclán yo me imagino cómo
murió mi hijo
horrible cada día de forma religiosa a
nancy así está el proceso solo faltó en
febrero cuando regresó a chile para
conocer a su nieto pero también porque
necesitaba urgentemente hacer una pausa
en la recta final la chilena considera
que las penas que pidieron los fiscales
no son lo suficientemente severas luego
venía con nuestras expectativas que
estos tipos no salieran nunca más de la
cárcel que quieto porque todo para mí
todos son
uno en mayor o menor medida pero todos
contribuyeron para que todo esto pasara
tras cada audiencia la carga sea liviana
en parte gracias a la conversación con
otros familiares en el patio de la corte
nancy tiene ahora más información que
cuando llegó aunque muchas dudas no han
sido resueltas
en lisboa comenzó la segunda conferencia
de la onu sobre los océanos buscan una
cuarta internacional sobre las aguas de
alta mar pero aún no se vislumbra un
patrón
una emergencia oceánica así es como
define el secretario general de la onu
antonio guterres el estado general de
los océanos en la segunda conferencia de
las naciones unidas sobre este tema
el calentamiento global está llevando la
temperatura de los ciudadanos a niveles
récord creando tormentas más feroces y
frecuentes el nivel del mar está
subiendo las naciones insulares de baja
altitud se enfrentan a inundaciones al
igual que muchas de las principales
ciudades costeras del mundo cities
indujo la onu afirma que los océanos se
enfrentan a una grave amenaza por el
calentamiento global la contaminación y
la acidificación por ello unas 7000
personas de 120 países entre jefes de
estado científicos y ong evaluarán los
avances en la aplicación de una
directiva para proteger la vida marina
la conferencia busca adoptar una
declaración que ayudaría a implementar y
facilitar la protección y conservación
de los océanos y sus recursos aunque
está aún fuera del alcance un acuerdo
internacional conocido como tratado de
alta mar que vaya más allá de la
jurisdicción nacional
activistas consternados por el fracaso
en políticas de protección protestaron
en las playas de lisboa
los océanos están vacíos estamos
capturando menos peces ahora que hace 30
años con todos los avances y tecnologías
necesitamos una acción adecuada que no
estamos viendo por parte de nuestros
líderes no se informara la ley tras el
océano cubre alrededor del 70% de la
superficie del planeta genera el 50 por
ciento del oxígeno y absorbe el 25 por
ciento de las emisiones de dióxido de
carbono pero unos 8 millones de
toneladas de residuos plásticos llegan a
las aguas cada año y si no se toman
medidas en los polímeros podrían superar
a todos los peces de los océanos en 2050
además al absorber más del 90% del
exceso de calor provocado por el
calentamiento global se han generado
olas de calor marinas masivas que están
acabando con los preciosos arrecifes de
coral indispensables para la
supervivencia de las especies bajo el
agua sigan con nosotros
[Música]